this is the BBC Plaza suffered further
any bullying rate last night
welcome to mr. information still vision
roughly seems to think you're what we
need for doing light will need to matter
what the floor stop or in this dialogue
record it was a secretarial pool
who's got think about yourself 30
million attend the cinema every week
your film must show your American
sisters but this is a war the husband
should be fighting cause you think no
screen credit doctors if we can't pay
you as much as a chance in this give
them character with whom they can
identify Uncle Frank sexy looks older we
all have a part of man defeating his not
this part the corpse role is dead before
the end of act 3 so that's what Puma and
then for Opel hello oh hey certainly
know a lot of men are scared we won't go
back into our boxes when this is over
the works good very good at wiener
we'll have them weeping in the aisle
with the worst night of bombing yet mrs.
I thought she was honoring sorry I can't
anymore
you may give an opportunity only because
young men are gone but the turn our back
on that opportunity will not be giving
death dominion over life girls like us
we burn all those people who gave birth
them to one wall and now their grandson
to another
it always is doc even if I were dead I
admit I might miss you
have you seen it how come I'm illegal
sorry
this is cold up where is she
chart could someone please get mr.
Hilliard out of Dunkirk
[Music]
you